[Music]
Big Bang Theory star Kevin Sussman is a
married man not his shoes boxes of
tissues and fans are gonna need him
after seeing the wedding photo he posted
on Instagram announcing he tied the knot
with Eddie Hall who said yes to Kevin's
proposal last year it's going to be like
a competition for the crying and Kevin
snap of the wedding day 80 wears a
strapless gown as she carries a bouquet
of roses the caption did I mention I got
married this weekend and next to the
couple Kevin's father he joked on his
Instagram story just got married me not
my dad is this what you do when I'm not
here make really good points
Kevin's Big Bang co-star Kunal Nair
dropped his congrats in the comments oh
my God love you brother I'll get the
hospital bag I blew the van up me
outside in two minutes steam baby go
this comes after both actors said
goodbye to their characters Raj and
Stewart in 2019 when the long-running
sitcom signed off after 12 Seasons what
would happiness look like with Stuart
unconditional love someone that
accepts Stewart with all of his neuroses
me Hallie and Denise played hide and
seek all day oh that's nice yeah
yeah I found Denise right away
you know Stuart he's a he's a fighter
and so like he these things happen to
him but he keeps going you know but long
before Kevin walked down the aisle
Stewart watched Sheldon and Amy say I do
I don't remember ever being on a Wookie
home plan
actually Luke was on The Wookie home
planet kashyyk in the holiday special
when he helped Chewie get home to his
wife
okay even if Luke Skywalker wasn't at
Kevin's wedding he still got plenty to
celebrate in this new chapter congrats
to the happy couple
[Music]